there are lots of ways to have some
application but how do you know which
makes the most sense for you and your
company join us as we talk with some
Keable about how they made it happen on
this episode of stack chat Mike thanks
so much for joining us can you tell us a
little more about what funcle' does sure
thunka bowl is a platform that allows
you to build mobile apps without code so
if you're a person that has an idea and
you're not an engineer which not
everyone is you can snap some blocks
together drag some components onto the
screen and not bring your idea to life
and we have about half a million users
and about a million apps built okay can
you tell us a little bit about from the
architecture side how thunka will manage
the server-side application that people
then use to build their own applications
sure we started off with a pretty simple
architecture we had a small user base
just trying to get it out there so we
had a single instance connected to a
cloud [ __ ] and cloud Redis and that the
database is scaled automatically but
that single instance led to some issues
there was a manual deploy so whenever
redeployed it went down and also we had
a lot of odd if you had an unhandled
exception it would bring down the whole
serve herself so I think this is a
common problem that a lot of startups
and small teams run into as they try to
focus on the application and don't
unfortunately spend as much time on the
infrastructure how did your team choose
to address these problems we pretty
quickly realized we needed multiple
instances so we spun up a couple more
but we were still doing manual deploys
and so now we had to do three of them
and it was great that we had less
downtime that's super important and that
the exceptions weren't taking down the
entire service but was taking too much
time so we quickly went to a docker
build which allowed us to automated
build that we can build on our own
machines we'd push it to Google Cloud
and then just deploy it to each of the
instances manually and then shortly
after that we realized that kubernetes
could do this for us so we just allow
kubernetes to deploy our images to as
many instances as we need so now you're
using manage infrastructure and you get
all the benefits of that but it sounds
like you're still doing the build
manually correct it took about a half an
hour on our local machines so we we took
a look at a Google cloud build and we
got it up and running there and it
wasn't necessarily faster but we weren't
sitting there watching it and which is
basically faster so the other thing was
before we weren't exactly sure what was
on production it was kind of like up to
us to make sure that we deployed the
right stuff but now we just tagged our
master branch and then Google Cloud
build kicks off and deploys it to our
staging environment so it's quite a bit
easier so it sounds like your team
learned a lot over time and then
implemented those changes but if you
knew everything you knew now back then
what would you have done differently the
first thing I definitely would have done
was just started with docker and
kubernetes it was nice to live through
the pain points that it solves but I
could have watched a three-minute video
one thing we did do right was every few
weeks we look at our kind of DevOps
process and see where our pain points
were and try to address them and some of
the things that we've fixed recently is
our docker build we've added docker
layer caching so that we can speed up
our builds from like 30 minutes to 5
minutes if it's just a quick back-end
fix so that's been really helpful the
other thing is making our docker image
much smaller has led to faster
employments and we did that with our
multistage builds which allow the final
product to have just what it needs to
run in production and it's always having
faster deploys is really important when
you're constantly pushing things and
want the ability to quickly deploy a
hotfix or new features thank you so much
for coming in here and telling us about
how your team kind of navigated both
maintaining the application and
improving the infrastructure at the same
time any time want to try using Google
Cloud build & kubernetes for yourself
check out the tutorial in the
description to get some hands-on
experience
thanks for watching and make sure to
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform content we'll see you next time
on stack chat
[Music]
you